la siguiente tabla enlista los valores
de f g
y de sus derivadas f prima y g prima
para los valores de x-men 2 y 4
así es que aquí tenemos una tabla con
los valores de x menos 2 y 4 y para cada
uno de estos valores tenemos los valores
correspondientes de f
efe prima y que prima definamos la
función f mayúscula como la composición
de las funciones f y g
así es que f mayúscula de x es igual a
efe minúscula de g de x y lo que
queremos hacer en este ejercicio es
encontrar f prima de 4 o sea la derivada
de f mayúscula evaluada en 4 ahora tal
vez inmediatamente te das cuenta de que
como ésta es una función compuesta
podemos utilizar la regla de la cadena y
bueno aquí simplemente estoy volviendo a
escribir la regla de la cadena la
derivada de f mayúscula de x va a ser
igual a la derivada de efe minúscula
evaluada en la función interior o sea f
prima evaluada en g de x que bueno esto
también lo podemos ver como la derivada
de toda esta función
respecto a la función interior y luego
queremos multiplicar por la derivada de
la función interior con respecto a x
osea
primer de x ahora si lo que realmente
queremos es encontrar f prima de 4
efe mayúscula prima de 4 bueno lo único
que tenemos que hacer es que cada que
encontremos una equis la sustituimos por
un 4 así es que f mayúscula prima de 4
es igual a efe prima de g de 4
je primer de cuatro y ahora como
encontramos esto bueno pues aquí tenemos
una tabla no nos han dado todos los
valores de estas funciones para todas
las equis pero sí para las equis que
necesitamos y lo primero que sería bueno
encontrar es cuánto es
de 4 y bueno eso nos lo dicen por acá
cuando x es igual a 4 g de x es igual a
menos 2 el valor que toma de x cuando x
es igual a 4 es menos 2
así es que esto de aquí es igual a menos
2 entonces esta parte de aquí es f prima
de menos 2 y cuánto es f prima de menos
bueno pues cuando x es igual a menos 2
efe prima de x es 1 así es que esto es f
prima de menos 2 y esto es igual a 1 y
ahora sólo nos falta encontrar cuánto es
que prima de 4 y cuando x es igual a 4
que prima de x toma el valor 8
así es que g prima de 4 es 8 y ya casi
terminamos efe mayúscula prima de 4
por 8 que es 8 y listo